the pentagon's report on ufos or uaps
unidentified aerial phenomena was
released to congress and a big takeaway
is
many of the anomalous objects that
appear in the report remain
unidentified to understand why experts
and pilots remain baffled
we spoke to veteran pilot andrea finley
i am currently a pilot
for major airlines flying 737s and i was
previously
a colonel in the air force i flew the
f-15c eagle
the t-38 talon and the t6 texan ii
and i was an instructor in all three of
those airframes ultimately
pilots seem to be the ones who are
seeing a lot of these
objects because they are out over the
ocean flying i can't imagine being in
their shoes and seeing what they saw i
think it would be
terrifying to not know what this object
was
colonel then is going to walk us through
videos of unidentified aerial phenomena
and explain the traits that make them
unidentifiable from a physics and
aerodynamics perspective
let's unpack the first trait
anti-gravity
the acorn shape pyramid shape and the
spherical shape they seem to overcome
gravity without any visible propulsion
or any airfoils that provide
lift or what we would traditionally call
a wing since the dawn of aviation on
earth which has been about 120 years now
normally lift is produced when an
aircraft increases speed
the air goes over the top of the wing
and the bottom of the wing
and meets at the end of the wing at the
same time
but because the top of the wing is a
different size than the bottom
it's going to create a negative pressure
because it's traveling faster
and it essentially sucks the wing and
the rest of the aircraft into that
negative pressure area and that's what
we refer to as lift
okay so the unidentified aerial
phenomena don't appear to have
recognizable wings for lyft
but what about their propulsion
i'm watching the gimbal video this was
filmed in 2015
and as you can see at the top it's using
the infrared sensor and that is depicted
by the
ir at the top of the screen there the
pod has multiple sensors it has both an
electro optical
sensor and an infrared sensor to detect
targets
what's noticeable is that there's no
visible infrared exhaust plume coming
from this object
and that indicates no source of
propulsion as we know it
where you see wht which stands for white
hot
so the cooler heat signatures will
appear as black and the hottest targets
are going to be
displayed as white a normal fighter size
target will have a heat signature that
can be detected
approximately 10 nautical miles away
with an infrared sensor
the skin friction of an aircraft enough
flying through the air
is going to be able to give a heat
signature so that a targeting pot will
be able to detect it
these objects don't seem to generate
exhaust so it's difficult to understand
how they're creating propulsion this
leads to the second unidentifiable trait
they fly at hyper speed
at 180 knots right now that is the
actual closing
velocity of that target to the
post-owned ship the f-18 that's carrying
the pod
from the bottom there on the left-hand
side you see the f-18s air speed 258
nautical miles per hour or
mach 0.62 and you can roughly tell if
you
do some rough math that that object is
going approximately 500 miles per hour
without any visible propulsion or any
airfoils that provide
lift that's fast but not supersonic fast
so let's consider the video taken during
the 2004 uss nimitz encounter
you can see at the very end the video
here this aircraft just
scoots off the screen very quickly based
on that and based on the testimony of
the
uss princeton operators that found that
object
60 miles away several seconds later it's
clear
that this object was traveling at very
high rates of speed with a lot of
acceleration
according to the calculations of the uss
princeton radar team
the so-called tic-tac-uap would have
reached a maximum speed of about 46
000 miles per hour during a descent or
60 times the speed of sound
as a point of comparison the fastest
manned aircraft that the us air force
has
ever operationally produced is the
lockheed sr-71 blackbird
which flew at mach 3.2 or three times
the speed of sound
the experimental north american x-15
which flew about mach 6.7
or 4500 miles per hour in 1967
but what about present-day tech it's no
secret that the united states as well as
multiple other countries are working on
hypersonic technology
and hypersonic means anywhere from five
times the speed of sound to ten times
the speed of sound it's
pretty quick so the boeing x51 wave
rider is one of those such vehicles this
is an
unmanned vehicle that's capable of
flying up to 70
000 feet and up to mach 5. other
countries that have this technology or
are working on it include
india russia and china for example
another attribute of uaps that make them
tricky to observe is stealth
most of these images are infrared
sensors that are just capturing the heat
signature of the aircraft
this video is using night vision video
on the deck of a
u.s navy destroyer and the shape itself
is unusual it's similar to our
b2 which has stealth technology but it's
not quite the same shape
it's possible that the pyramid shape is
flat
regular surfaces that would deflect
radar energy and not let it return to
the host
it's possible that that is a stealth
technology and that's why
operators have had trouble capturing
this on their radars
stealth crafts work to scramble radar in
two ways first with irregular flat
surfaces like the b2 bomber that will
not easily return the radar beam
and second by using radar absorbing
materials on the craft's exterior
it's unclear why it is flashing but some
of it might have to do
with the quality of the camera or the
night vision video that they have
it's really tough to tell what the
actual colors are or if it is metallic
or silver
and yet the us doesn't have a monopoly
on planes that confuse radar
the chinese have the j-20 the russians
fly the
su-57 and then japan south korea
indonesia
they all have fairly advanced stealth
technology programs
another anomalous trait uaps seem to
have is that they are transmitting
splash transmedium just means that these
objects are moving easily between
different environments such as space
our atmosphere and even underwater this
video was taken from off the coast of
san diego
and the most notable feature is the
ability to fly both in
air and underwater as soon as the object
nears the water they are waiting to mark
the accordance the bearing and range of
where this object went down and they are
i don't know i'm not sure
this video i was like i don't know that
i can really because there's nothing we
have that's even remotely close to this
so
i i don't even really know what to say
about it it looks like
it did go into the water you think that
the object has crashed
however when submarines went to go look
for the object
there was no trace of its remains
what's significant about that is that it
probably has a capability
to also travel under the water we have
nothing here in the united states
anyway that can operate as both an
aircraft and a submarine
a recently leaked video of what is
allegedly the radar screen aboard the
uss
omaha might support the jaw-dropping
assertion that this uap
dropped into the water and swam away
as investigators sift through the
mountain of data connected to the uap
report colonel themly will keep an open
mind
and her eyes on the sky there are
possibilities that
some of these aircraft could be foreign
adversarial aircraft that are
coming here to collect intelligence
there's possibilities that there are
individuals within the united states
that are creating this technology
we don't know what this is and there are
a lot of unanswered questions still they
seem to defy
every law of physics and aerodynamics
that we know
i'm excited that these questions are
going to start being answered again i'm
a skeptic
i want proof i want to be able to see
and believe something so
i'm glad that the pentagon is doing
investigation so we can actually
figure out what these objects are